here's a question for you
um
so
you so
the bigger names that are supporters of
ethereum it's not small names no these
are big names big right uh the big uh
hedge funds that are bullish on
uh ethereum these are not small names
these are
very very well-known names right that
you're you're talking about fortress
arc investment group uh brevin
renaissance there's some of these bigger
names billions yeah billions so which
means they have access
to uh uh uh they are banking on them
being it so is this
a situation where ethereum
um
doesn't want an xrp and it's a form of
wanting to eliminate competition is that
all it is or it's a form of let's get
rid of these guys and let's not put the
attention on us let's get the attention
to xrp is that kind of what this is sure
i think joe lubin said it best i said
when he said
that every altcoin
is
is spectacularly disadvantaged when
compared to ethereum he said bitcoin and
ether we've been blessed we have the
regulatory past we have the free pass
these other folks don't yeah and and
look at how much activity went to
ethereum since that speech in 2018
what half of nfts are in ethereum the
article just came out right i'm looking
at this article ethereum joe lubin
defense sccm at ripple lawsuit
uh as the sec is facing uh barrage of
criticism for its uh scatter shot
approach to regulatory cryptocurrencies
the much feared regulatory agency as a
supporter within the industry consensus
ceo
joe lubin and in a recent interview with
the information lubin who is known as
one ethereum co-founders claims that the
sec chair gary
demands for greater authority in
regulating cryptos are justified the
head of ethereum development studio says
that the agency has a lot of legit
arguments
may have legit arguments in the cases
that are being discussed right now while
ripple the company that was sued by cc
in december over its unregistered
security sales accuses the agency of
stifling innovation in the u.s lubin
does not think that is the case i don't
believe the sec is trying to squelch
innovation and he continues
making other comments about it ripples
adam that xrp was treated on fairly by
the sec a speech by william henman the
sec's former top official in which he
said that ether was not an unregistered
security became a breeding ground for
conspiracy theories about potential
interests within the xrp community some
are convinced that hinman had skin in
the game merely because of his ties to
simpson thatcher law firm which is
member of the enterprise ethereum
alliance yet the sec made it clear that
it has not taken an official position on
its regulatory status and hinman was
only expressing his personal opinion
ripple theobrad is careful about his
words choice steering clear of peddling
free pass conspiracy theories in a
recent interview however he said that
the timing of the lawsuit was suspicious
so now why is uh
everybody likes dogecoin what is brad's
issue with dogecoin
you know i don't know other than i think
it comes down to the utility argument
that you brought up where you said
elon's being smart elon knows exactly
what you said right so he's going to get
you know him and mark cuban who's also
into doge they're they're selling their
merchandise dallas maverick merchandise
tesla merchandise and they're using
smart they're using doze as a means of
payment yeah and so it's going to drive
it up and um and he's right the the the
reality is dogecoin as a means of
payment transaction is better than
bitcoin on the network there's no doubt
about it you know bitcoin right now it's
digital gold it's a store of value and
that's why you should buy it that's the
use case for bitcoin you know ethereum
it's the smart contracts and they're the
2.0 eventually and all that's going to
happen that's their story with ripple it
is these superior payment transactions
you can
literally send there's a guy named
michael arrington and he moved 50
million dollars
um
into his uh uh
balance sheet and it cost him thirty
dollars well that's an extra that was
the argument that i had heard against
xrp was the the drug trafficking
argument like okay you can
you can buy two million dollars of
cocaine and have it in uh you know
colombia for 30 bucks in in 10 minutes
and that's you know so it's gonna it's
gonna make the the drug trafficking uh
international drug trafficking and all
smuggling you know that that much easier
and i'm saying like well they're doing
it anyway well it's also it's also
listen
it's all thought about the criminal
stuff because it's a public ledger the
cia and the fbi have come out and said
that they basically hope that terrorism
used the distributed ledger you can find
them it's an open legend
as well said that as well he said that
this is better for the fbi because now
they can catch the bad guy better
i don't know if that's true or not but
that's what he said pat they're full of
anyway man because look they got a
problem with the technology that could
do this but then the president's son is
selling a painting for two million
dollars like okay and then we're just
wasn't beautiful
i mean this guy is incredible like i'd
rather have the laptop shame on you for
discrediting
how dare i yeah i mean yeah it's uh
he's a real um he's a real crack uh
artist with the paint brush but i can't
speak for brad i just think it comes
down to that utility argument well i'll
read the article to you on why he said
that so here's the article that just
came out on why he has an issue i think
it's on page
five let me see here uh uh on the bottom
okay here we go bitcoin news uh dogecoin
is loved by all except brad garland
house dogecoin is arguably one of the
world's most popular most successful
cryptocurrencies in the world starting
out as a joke roughly eight years ago
and the currency has been established as
one of the most leading digital assets
of today as a marquee capital brown uh
more than a billion dollars and has
garnered attention from elon man mark
you and clearly it's popular coin and
everyone seems to like it except brad
garland cows the ceo ripple in recent
interviews stated that the asset was not
good in the long run when it came to
expansion of the crypto space he
mentioned i'm actually not convinced
somewhat controversially i guess that
dogecoin is good for the crypto market
dogecoin has some inflationary uh
dynamics itself that would make it
reluctant to hold it's interesting that
these words are coming from brad whose
coin xrp was ultimately out done by
dogecoin at one point doge eventually
rose so high
early this year that it became world's
fourth largest cryptocurrency by the
market and beat out xrp now uh though
now things have calmed down a bit
pushing those to the side garland cal
stated that the still feels bitcoin
holds the top position in crypto when it
came down to crypto currency serving as
an inflationary hedge tool he commented
when people are concerned about holding
a fiat currency that might be inflating
and that's devaluing they're looking at
how can i hold other assets that won't
have that same inflationary dynamic his
main issue with dogecoin is that
currency does not employ inflationary
barricades the way bitcoin does as of
now doge has approximately 132 billion
units outstanding while an additional 5
million new coins enter circulation
every year
so i guess that's the reason why he has
an issue with them in regards to
inflationary barricades well xrp is you
know it has a 100 billion it's not going
to get any more sort of a similar
argument to bitcoin instead of 21
million it's 100 billion and uh
but at the same time you know everyone's
in their tribe and crypto crypto is just
like a microcosm of everything else in
society everyone's in their tribe you
know when you had kurt on
he's a bsv guy yeah that's it like you
asked him well is there going to be two
or three coins that are going to you
know come out of this and be winners and
psp is the one true god you know that
was it whereas i take that position
there's what 7 000 coins most of them
going to go away but there's going to be
you know a handful that make it i think
xrp is going to make it in the payment
sector i think bitcoin is going to
continue to be that digital gold you
know s store value and if ethereum
if they end up figuring it out
then i think it could ultimately flip
bitcoin even
it could flip bitcoin i think it could
listen you know a lot of people say oh
you're the xrp attorney and you're
hating on ether i have a higher
investment in ethereum than i do xrp
this this isn't about me this is about
what's right what's right it's about
that reaction that you had as you were
learning this right and the only
difference is i have a law degree and i
said i can do something about it
but i read some word the supporters of
xrp i saw kutcher i saw madonna snoop
dogg but the most random character bill
clinton
yeah they what is bill clinton and xrp
let me tell you something about ripple
you know we've already went over there
their their defense lineup right their
lawyers
they had bill clinton be their keynote
speaker at their annual event
on their board just this year is
a former u.s
treasury the her name rosie something is
rios is on the dollars and the 100 bills
she was the treasurer of the united
states she's on their board so they have
top-notch people from the industry uh
not just the crypto industry but the
financial industry are they putting bill
clinton on that list because he spoke at
an event are they putting bill clinton
on that list because he owns xrp maybe
they paid him an xrp to speak i don't
know i i think it's more about just that
list he's a fiance i don't know why
former president coming on board yeah
because because it's the right guy to
have on your side because you're dealing
with a lot of liberals on the opposing
side that want to you know regulate the
hell out of you in a phone call from
bill clinton and even scarier phone
calls from his wife you kind of have to
take that call and say all right hillary
we'll we'll leave xrp yeah that sentence
that you said man 2021 is such a trip
there's a lot of liberals that want to
regulate you like these words don't even
mean anything anymore you know who owns
xrp tim draper i know he owns xrp
the wolf of wall street jordan balfour
jordan belfort uh owns xrp and i think
uh jason derulo and maybe exhibit
maybe exhibit i think i saw him on
twitter one of my favorite exhibit songs
of all time
back in the 90s yeah but uh uh it's a
shame uh uh
people in the rap game only for the
money and the fame extra large remember
that yeah like that was years ago the
opening was sick so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you